quatre thématiques principales les têtes
de listes guyancourt toise ou leurs
colistiers présenté à des habitants leur
programme notre programme c'est pas une
série de mesures que l'on vérifie six
ans après qu'on a fait mais qu' on est
vraiment dans un système c'est à dire
par exemple si on met de l'agriculture
sur les terrains de la minière c'est
aussi pour faire du lien social c'est
aussi pour faire de la pédagogie
vis-à-vis des écoles c'est aussi pour
alimenter une cantine et c'est aussi
pour créer des emplois sert bouclé
toutes les pistes on a des pistes qui
sont
les quartiers ne se joignent pas n'y a
pas de jointure entre les quartiers on a
des pistes qui sont en piteux état il
faut les reconstruire il faut les
sécuriser il faut les aménager et il
faut permettre à nos habitants de
circuler d'avoir les promesses des
commerces de proximité pour pouvoir y
aller à pied
voilà c'est un tout une tour aménagé 15
minutes pour convaincre après un tirage
au sort sur la question politique
alimentaire l'équipe de rodolphe barry
souhaite notamment installer une cuisine
centrale l'idée c'est de la m en même
temps fait la conscient même temps que
le nouveau centre technique municipal
et puis 10 mètres d'une personne
professionnelle aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de personnel professionnel de la cuisine
à la mairie après il y aura deux
possibilités c'est quelque chose qu'on
qu'on étudie encore c'est soit la voir
en régisseur nous-mêmes ou soit
externaliser la prestation la nourriture
bio ou labellisés bio les circuits
courts en priorité et puis le travail
sur le non gaspillage également sur la
question de la construction le maire
sortant françois morton a souhaité
mettre en avant l'idée d'une mixité une
construction en soi n'a pas de sens si
on ne met pas ce qu'il ya derrière c'est
à dire des êtres humains notamment dans
le cadre de leur logement
il s'agit alors d'habitat ou de leur
travail et on peut parler à ce moment-là
de développement économique ou de
services aux habitants au travers des
services publics
donc on ne construit pas un bâtiment
pour construire un bâtiment il a
forcément une fonction le public a
ensuite pu poser des questions et
inquiétudes sur les étangs de la minière
teck de transition ou encore démocratie
participative à l'origine du débat le
collectif guyancourt toit pour le climat
aujourd'hui il ya un problème au niveau
de
de l'environnement de la pollution du
réchauffement climatique ce sont des
thématiques qui ont pas été prise
suffisamment au sérieux dans le passé
dans le récent passé donc aujourd'hui il
est absolument indispensable de mettre
l'accent sur ces sur ces sujets et qu'il
y ait des actions qui soient efficaces
pour lutter contre ces problèmes
un absent pour cette soirée ma belle à
des qte les têtes de liste union des
démocrates musulmans français excusé
pour des raisons de santé
une centaine de personnes a assisté à la
soirée